Why What I am so irresponsible and
before you guys criticize me yeah I'm
gonna say all the terrible things about
myself I'm an idiot I am a careless I'm
reckless
accidents happen oh my god the same
exact thing that happened the last time
I shattered my phone it happened again
I'm holding my dog in this hand and the
phone also in this hand he pulls and the
phone just drops oh I just Maddie why
why do you break mommy's phone
I had blamed the dog he doesn't know any
better he just wants to go for a walk
thankfully I have a Genius Bar
appointment in an hour as soon as I
picked my phone up I was like oh God
again and I was able to schedule it as
quickly as possible so what I have to do
now because the last time that I made
this mistake I backed up everything to
iCloud and it took almost three weeks to
backup all my photos in every place only
to the backup from iCloud I'm now gonna
back up onto my computer lightning to
USB see for you brows radius or how I
back this up
[Music]
my appointments at two o'clock so that
means hopefully this will back up within
a 45 minute I have no idea how long is
this gonna take but I hope it goes quick
[Music]
and why did I put this on my screen
sooner and you're probably also
wondering Justine why did you remove the
glass protection that you just told us
that you put on your phone so I remove
the glass screen because I was going to
reapply it because there's a big bubble
and I did a terrible job of putting it
on and guess what I never did I never
put it back on so Justine
you're an idiot it's your fault you're
so stupid but I bought this the other
day and I never even put it on my phone
so I was like I'd like to try the other
one first because the other screen that
I had had a little black edge along the
bottom so it hid the crack so with that
crack already being cracked and the drop
that I just dropped so I mean I'm the
Apple store put this on I'm bringing it
and they have like a really cool little
screen footer otter
[Music]
it's 537 pixel phone in you may notice
that the time that I planned on going
was way earlier in the day but my phone
did not back up in time so here we are
now we're off to the Apple store
[Music]
okay now we wait an hour and go and
check on our phone I should have planned
on going to the gym but I guess I'll go
to Starbucks
I just learned to Starbucks and I bought
something that I'm going to be making a
video about I would show you here but
what kind of youtuber would I be if I
gave away an incredible clickbait title
for this video and the thing is it's not
going to be clickbait because the title
is actually true of what i'm going to
show you in the video but it's such all
good I'm so excited I just turned in
this terrible day into a really great
day stuck in the door I know I'm just
gonna sit in my car because I have
nothing else to do for the next half
hour so
[Music]
all right we're going back to the Apple
store it's been about an hour I sat in
my car I ran out of things to do I
checked my email
don't know what else to do get my photos
ready
[Music]
here's my new phone link poor little guy
No
all right case is on it's time to go I
think everything is working out okay
it's not quite even but I tried my best
the best was not good
come back up Assam eating time remaining
come on let me know four minutes five
zero okay I see what's happening you
excited that I'm home honey honey
oh good sit very good
[Music]
good morning it's a day after the day
after the shatter everything looks to be
back in order I don't like the white
case on this phone at all it just
doesn't it doesn't look good the
aesthetic is off but I did find this in
a drawer this is our little baby
it's our classic iPhone it's the
original it started at all eight gigs
anyway I just want to say thanks for
watching and I'm going to try to be more
responsible yeah I don't know I just
look up I need my ear Bramante and I'm
gonna edit this video and alright well
thanks for watching hopefully I won't be
making any more of these videos so I'll
see you later
[Music]
well what was your favorite old-school
game and if you've never played any of
these games before what current game is
your favorite now I hate the spiny
funnies